I
we're with national master alina cats
alina you were the only wild card
invited to play in the US women's chess
championship and I understand you got
the news and a bit of a strange way tell
us about it yes actually got the news on
my birthday I was sitting in my house
with my friend and we were actually
talking because it's my junior year in
high school and we were talking about
how I'm not really involved and trust
that much because school work takes up
so much time and then I get this email
and it's like a note from God you know
start studying again and are you
studying gonna do yes definitely so what
the privilege comes responsibility
sounds like twice ok and you're
finishing out your year in school how
are you able to balance your your
studies and your essay p taking
everything oh well I just finished my
SATs yesterday so I got that out the way
and then I flew out here but I mean for
the past couple of months since I got
the news I just been you know balancing
a CT war 80 work chest work to try to do
everything at the same time now a lot of
chest fans came to noting the last few
weeks with the extreme Chess
Championships that were filmed in
Manhattan what was that experience like
being on the first chest reality show it
was very fun and different from anything
else I've ever done um I mean I knew
most of the people I I know the the
person that I was versing personally and
it was a fun experience well you're the
10th seat here would a 50-percent result
satisfy you or are you actually going
from one more I'd be more than happy I
mean I'm sure I'm really trying to do my
best because it's my first time but you
know 50 result would make me really
happy now there are three people here at
the u.s. championships and Women's
Champion
ships that are students of your father
alexander landman Irina's any yolk and
you you're the ultimate student what did
your dad just come home from teaching
other friends and other students and
then come home and teach you at night or
how did that relationship work I mean
Iowa he has his own chess club and it's
located like pretty much across the
street from our house so I just go there
a lot I work there I teach little kids
and we just kind of bounce at our
relationship with chess and father
daughter time said you go to Brighton
Beach a lot and play right there on the
boardwalk um I used to do that when I
was younger now I don't have much time
so I just go to tournaments right well I
hope you get your fifty percent result
may be even better yeah enjoy your time
in same way thank you so much